[Música]
economía danny primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en colombia ya
vimos el día de ayer y hoy damos un
repaso por algunas de las propuestas
económicas de los dos candidatos y
comenzamos por las polémicas pensiones
ácidas de raúl y es que estamos hablando
de dos candidatos que saben de lo que
van a hacer porque es un economista y un
ingeniero empresario de toda la vida
quienes se rinden en esta contienda
además de la sostenibilidad fiscal y
combatir la creciente inflación las
pensiones son efectivamente uno de los
principales retos económicos que
afrontará el próximo presidente del país
y es que según la asociación nacional de
instituciones financieras apenas el 22
por ciento en edad de jubilarse recibe
este ingreso en el país hay dos
modalidades la pública y la privada y al
estado le cuesta mucho dinero mantener
este régimen público por eso el tema ha
sido objeto de múltiples debates en los
que valga la pena decirlo el candidato
rodolfo hernández no ha participado el
aspirante de izquierda gustavo petro
propone una reforma estructural que
fortalezca el sistema público y que sin
tocar la edad de jubilación que es de 62
años para hombres y de 57 para mujeres
garantice al menos un ingreso de
pensiones por encima de la línea de
pobreza su contendor buscaría aumentar
los subsidios pensionales para personas
de escasos recursos es decir reducir la
brecha con las pensiones altas y dotar
de un salario mínimo mensual a aquellos
a quienes no les alcanzan los recursos
para pensionarse o las semanas cotizadas
mejor así están y cambiamos entonces
ahora el tema los retos y las propuestas
en materias de empleo bueno si bien la
cifra de desempleo en colombia es
no baja pero si al nivel de sus pares en
américa latina y se ha mantenido en un
buen tiempo en un dígito se ha
recuperado después de la pandemia pues
la reactivación todavía está rezagada y
el mayor problema es la informalidad que
afecta a uno de cada dos trabajadores
por lo menos gustavo petro propone entre
otras cosas replantear los tratados de
libre comercio para crear nuevos puestos
de trabajo y que el estado ofrezca
empleo a quienes no lo encuentran en el
sector privado
que su contrincante rodolfo hernández
plantea exenciones tributarias para la
creación de emprendimientos digitales y
también dice que va a fortalecer el
ministerio de trabajo para que
identifique cuáles son esos sectores
laborales más activos y así poder
protegerlos y en lo que más difieren los
candidatos danny es en la transición
energética claro bien es que colombia es
un país que depende mucho del petróleo
solamente por citarle un ejemplo 4 de
cada 10 dólares que exporta provienen de
este sector y el futuro de la industria
nos gustaría mucho según el aspirante
que llegue a la casa de nariño gustavo
petro por un lado quiere transitar muy
rápidamente hacia otras fuentes de
energía eliminando los incentivos al
sector minero-energético incentivos
tributarios
dejando de otorgar también licencias
para exploración de hidrocarburos y de
gran minería a cielo abierto esto es
difícil en un país que por ejemplo tiene
algunas de las más grandes minas de
carbón a cielo abierto del mundo como lo
es el cerrejón en la guajira también
detendría el desarrollo de los llamados
de ella de los yacimientos costa afuera
que es de donde proviene gran parte del
gas natural que consume el país y
también los pilotos de fracking el
fracturamiento hidráulico de rocas para
extraer petróleo contrario a lo que
piensa su rival rodolfo hernández quien
además promovería el desarrollo de
energía eólica y solar pero no ha dado
detalles sobre cómo lo haría bueno
esperemos que esos detalles los de
pronto y cambiamos de tema vamos a
hablar ahora de la inflación en europa
específicamente vamos a hablar de españa
y de alemania que son los países que ya
revelaron el dato previo a que lo haga
eurostat que aglutina a finalmente a
todos los países de la unión europea en
el país hermano la inflación alcanzó su
nivel más alto en casi medio siglo en
mayo la razón tiene que ver con los
precios de los alimentos y los
combustibles que vienen subiendo a su
ritmo más rápido en varios años como
también ocurre en españa' que anotó en
marzo su peor dato de inflación desde
1985 ya en abril se había recuperado y
en mayo volvió a retomar su tendencia
alcista la inflación acumulada entonces
en este país en los últimos 12 meses se
aceleró hasta el 87 por ciento y lo que
sí bajó fue el precio de la electricidad
indicadores económicos raúl las acciones
mundiales subieron este lunes después de
que wall street se recuperara de una
serie de caídas de siete semanas y
también después de que china relajará
las restricciones antivirus sobre la
actividad comercial tanto en shanghái
como en beijing las bolsas europeas
operan mixtas en medio del inicio de una
reunión de líderes de dos días en
bruselas para discutir de nuevo sobre el
posible embargo de petróleo a rusa y
sobre el cual estaremos informando así
es danny muchísimas gracias como siempre
por toda la información económica nos
vemos mañana con más economía aquí en
directo américa y pensamos ahora hablar
con las mentes de deportes